♪ ♪
>> Laura: AS CORONAVIRUS
DEATHS ACROSS THE GLOBE HIT MORE
THAN 230,000, WELL, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS MAKING EFFORTS
NOW TO HOLD CHINA ACCOUNTABLE.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," SENIOR
OFFICIALS ACROSS MULTIPLE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES WERE MEETING
TODAY TO "BEGIN MAPPING OUT A
STRATEGY FOR SEEKING RETALIATORY
MEASURES AGAINST CHINA.
WHAT WILL THAT MEAN?
TRUMP AND DATES HAVE DISCUSSED
STRIPPING CHINA OF ITS SOVEREIGN
IMMUNITY, AIMING TO ENABLE THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT OR
VICTIMS TO SUE CHINA FOR
DAMAGES.
A TOP CHINESE OFFICIAL YESTERDAY
REFUSED THOUGH TO ACCEPT
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> THOSE DEMANDS FOR REPARATIONS
FROM CHINA ARE NOT REASONABLE
AND THEY HAVE NO LEGAL BASIS AND
IN FACT I THINK THERE IS NO
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SUCH DEMANDS
AND BLACKMAIL.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW IS
NIKKI HALEY, FORMER U.S.
AMBASSADOR TO THE U.N. AND OF
COURSE, GOVERNOR OF
SOUTH CAROLINA.
AMBASSADOR HALEY, FIRST OF ALL,
IT’S GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON THE
SHOW, WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT
TONIGHT.
HE SAID BLACKMAIL, AMBASSADOR
HALEY, WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
THAT?
>> THIS IS WHAT THE CHINESE DO.
THIS IS WHAT -- THE TWO YEARS I
WAS WITH THE UNITED NATIONS,
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO.
THEY BASICALLY WILL CALLOUT
OTHERS AND SAY THINGS TO OTHERS,
BUT THEY DON’T WANT IT SENT BACK
TO THEM.
AND YOU KNOW, THE TRUTH IS THE
CHINESE ARE NEVER GOING TO ADMIT
FAULT.
I NEVER GOING TO ADMIT THAT THEY
DID ANYTHING WRONG AND THAT’S
WHY THE UNITED STATES HAS TO BE
SMART.
WE HAVE TO STRATEGICALLY FIGURE
OUT HOW WE ARE GOING TO DEAL
WITH CHINA FOR THE LONG TERM AND
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE CALL
THEM OUT AND LET THEM KNOW THAT
WE ARE ONTO THEM.
>> Laura: WHAT’S THE ARGUMENT
LEFT AT THIS POINT,
AMBASSADOR HALEY, THAT WE SHOULD
NOT BE TREATING CHINA THE WAY WE
TREATED THE FORMER SOVIET UNION?
WHERE WE BASICALLY DID VERY
LITTLE TRADE, WE DID VERY FEW
EDUCATIONAL EXCHANGES.
I WAS IN ONE OF THEM, SO I KNOW.
WE JUST BASICALLY DIDN’T COUPLE
WITH THEM AT ALL ON KEY
INITIATIVES, SO WHY SHOULDN’T WE
TREAT CHINA THE SAME WAY?
>> WE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD TREAT
CHINA THE SAME WAY.
THIS IS ABOUT THE FACT THAT
CHINA IS OUR NUMBER ONE NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT.
THEY ARE INCREASINGLY MILITARY
AND THAT NEEDS TO PUT OUR
MILITARY ON NOTICE.
THEY’VE BEEN STEALING
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING AND THE PRESIDENT
NEEDS TO HOLD FIRM THAT IF THEY
DO IT, WE PUT SANCTIONS AND
TARIFFS BACK ON THEM.
THEY HAVE CREATED A SURVEILLANCE
STATE, LITERALLY THEIR PEOPLE
DON’T KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON IN
THE REST OF THE WORLD UNLESS
CHINA APPROVES IT.
THEY HAVE A MILLION MINORITIES
IN CONCENTRATION CAMPS, MAKING
THEM CHANGE THEIR NAMES, CHANGE
THEIR RELIGION AND THE WAY THEY
DO THINGS.
>> Laura: INVESTOR HALEY,
TODAY THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE CONFIRMED THAT THE
U.S. DOES BELIEVE COVID-19 COULD
HAVE BEEN THE RESULT OF AN ACCID
IN WUHAN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE’S SEEN
CONVINCING EVIDENCE OF THE SAME
BUT "THE NEW YORK TIMES" SEEMS
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
ANY AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE REPORT
BLAMING A CHINESE INSTITUTION
OFFICIAL FOR THE OUTBREAK COULD
SIGNIFICANTLY HARM RELATIONS
WITH CHINA YEARS TO COME.
SO "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
WORRIED ABOUT OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH CHINA WHEN ALL THESE
AMERICANS HAVE DIED AND
30 MILLION AMERICANS ARE OUT OF
WORK BECAUSE OF THIS VIRUS,
AMBASSADOR.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE CHINESE
RELATIONSHIP WHEN TAIWAN CAME
OUT DECEMBER 30TH AND SAID THEY
SAW PERSON-TO-PERSON CONTACT IN
TERMS OF COVID?
WHERE WAS CHINA WHEN THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION ASKED
QUESTIONS ON THE 14TH AND THEY
STALLED?
WHERE WAS CHINA EVEN UP UNTIL
THE 30TH OF JANUARY, WHERE THE
JUST WANT US TO STOP TRADE?
THEY KNEW WHAT WAS HAPPENING AND
THEY DIDN’T TELL US.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT TODAY,
AMBASSADOR HALEY, SAID HE’S
TRYING TO WALK A FINE LINE, BUT
HE SAID HE THINKS CHINA HAS
TRIED TO BE TRANSPARENT.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> CHINA DOESN’T KNOW HOW TO BE
TRANSPARENT.
ALL THEY WANT IS WHAT THEY WANT
THE REST OF THE WORLD TO SEE.
THEIR PERCEPTION IS EVERYTHING.
IF I EVER WANTED TO GET UNDER
CHINA’S SKIN, ALL I DID WAS CALL
THEM OUT, BECAUSE THEY CAN’T
STAND TO BE CALLED OUT.
IF THEY WANT TO CREATE THE
NARRATIVE AND THEY TAKE ON THE
APPROACH THAT IF THEY SAY IT’S
TRUE, THEN THE WEST OF THE WORLD
WILL BELIEVE IT.